Right. I'm bored talking about anime. We're not even anatomy podcast anymore.
Imagine talking about anime on trash guys.
I feel like I'm, I'm attempting to be the Winnie, the Pooh meme, like the, the,
the like high class, or when I talk about adamant, I'm trying to full opinions.
I don't have opinions. I don't have, well,
I don't have well formed opinions about things. I just say what I feel. Okay.
I mean, you don't.
I have well formed opinions,
like Rick anime gaming, like let's,
let's be honest here.
All my streaming of the day being like, God is actually like,
your parents didn't beat you enough because like, because right,
listen, he was allowed to get away with not eating crust. Right.
If I didn't need my crop.
If I.
Didn't eat my cross. Right. You know what my parents would do. They'd be like,
that's fine. It, you have dinner ready for tomorrow. Now I'd be like, mom,
I don't, I don't want them. She's like, no, Connie, you crust.
Wasting food. Who says that? I didn't get my beat for not eating my cross.
I will not bow cross because I had gone my entire
childhood having to like being forced to eat my cross.
So as soon as I was a fully grown adult who can make my own decisions,
I'm going to be, I was, I was, I was like, mother,
I did not care what you think anymore. I'm going to not eat my cross.
I pay my own rent. I pay my own bills. I buy my own food. you, mother.
All I'm saying is you should got a backhand a little bit more.
Yeah. There is a bad joke.
There, there is. There is something that like,
I didn't fully appreciate as a kid or like,
I didn't fully cross like cross good food, not cross, but like,
I gotta to get a food by the way, whenever we're not getting into food again.
But like I was yesterday,
I was cleaning the house and I hate cleaning the house.
I don't think anyone in their entire life lies cleaning the house.
And I didn't realize why my parents basically just every parent
manipulates their kids to be like their personal slaves,
my jobs when it comes to like cleaning the house.
Oh, that's, that's the reason why they used to have so many kids. Right.
And it was like, they got to plow the fields. Right.
I intend to keep that British philosophy alive. When I have a kid,
he needs to plow the fields and clean the house and prepare them.
Yeah. Connor's going to like min backs. That. My house has a six rooms.
So that's six children. I need to have at least one per room.
I'm not, I'm not going to beat my kids by the way. That was a distasteful joke.
Just say that now.
Cause like, why is the, why is the like activity of cleaning?
Just so awful. Like,
like does anyone who, who actually enjoys cleaning the house when you do it?
Right.
When you have it, like, you get rid of a lot of dirt. Right?
That's why I let it, I let it build up. I let it get like gross.
Because when you clean that, it's like peeling off a good scab.
Oh, it's so clean. Yeah. But I need to see like a physical layer of dust.
For me. It'd be like,
when you swipe a whole layer of dust off with like a wet wipe or something,
that feels good. That takes, that caught a child at least.
But I don't like cleaning. It's not.
Because like, yeah, that, that is a satisfying feeling.
But my problem with is that cleaning just. Like I never knew as a kid,
how much time and effort it takes to clean. Like, because okay,
when you're a kid, you just clean your own room.
[inaudible] I didn't even do that or whatever. Oh, you, you lucky. You like,
I would, but then five minutes later, I'd be back to where it was.
So my parents were just like, whatever.
Like I still have Vietnam flashbacks of my mom calling me. Like,
I know she's about to ask you to Hoover the living room. I,
I don't want to come down right now. It's timeout having. But yeah.
Like, like I realized as an adult, the act of cleaning,
just like it takes you all day. And like,
the reason I hate it is because it feels like, you know,
when you do something productive, like you do,
you do like a hard day of work or something, or like even playing a video game.
You feel like you're making progress with your life. I don't know.
About the video game thing, but I like, like, you know, when, when, like for me,
whenever I'm playing like a.
First person game, like a single player game.
Yeah. Okay. Okay. Yeah.
[inaudible] cleaning like the whole,
the entire concept of cleaning is that you're working towards making things
zero. Again, you're working towards zero. You're walking,
you're working towards making things.
Oh, it switched off. Sorry. Uh, Joey, Joey a laptop is.
Yeah. You're working towards, towards making the default site, state zero again.
And I'm just like, this doesn't feel good yet.
It takes so much time and energy to do it. And no one prepared,
no one prepared this for me as a kid, it's like shoveling snow in a blizzard.
Right. It's gonna, it's gonna form back up again. So I was like,
what's the point?
I only used to clean. I'm like, like, this is how I would,
I would decide if I'm going to clean this day.
There's somebody coming to my house. No, I'm not cleaning.
If somebody comes to that is still, my staff is somebody coming to my house.
Fine. I'll clean.
You know what the best adult purchase I ever made was in the UK.
It was a good vacuum. I was like, you know what?
What's all this hype around those Dyson things. What is all that happened?
Cause I, I lived with a friend.
I lived with a guy and his dad worked for the Henry Henry Hoovers. Yeah.
It was like the.
Smile smiley face. Yeah.
We're in America. But everywhere in the UK, these things they're like tanks.
They don't die. But they also kind of suck. They don't suck good.
They should be sucking good. And I'm like, this guy in my house. I was like,
I wanted to get a Dyson. And he was like, no, no, no, no, no.
All you need is this thing. And he's like slaps it. He's like, it's a unit.
This thing is. And I, I, I broke it within like two weeks. Yeah.
What the we lock up? Well,
that'll do it. I was, Oh no. I have to get a new home quick.
Grab the Hoover. Oh no. I have to get a new, a new vacuum.
So I bought a Dyson dude. That cleaned up. Like it could have, Oh my God,
a copy. It was a different color. I was like,
what have I been doing my whole life. I never believed in that. Dies as the too.
Until I bought one lady a couple of years ago.
Changes the game. How good these are. And I do. I was like, all right.
Not buying anything else anymore.
Up to like max sock and like, Oh my God.
Good sock the. The max socket. Here's how I could. Okay.
This Dyson has all this.
About rotating things like 10 cylinder. It's a load of.
Let me say why it's good, right? Yeah.
You don't have one piece that always sticks. The carpet that doesn't come off.
Dyson never has an issue. Getting that one crumb out of the car.
That always comes out because the normal vacuums, they don't get that out.
Like there's always that one thing that for some reason won't come out,
you gotta it.
Yeah. And then you're like, how many, how many.
Rollovers am I going to do this thing until I just admit defeat, bend over,
pull out of the carpet, like an animal and feed it into the vacuum.
Like at some budget dog in my head.
I don't like doing that.
I'm not a peasant. I shouldn't have to touch my coffee with my hands.
That's disgusting. So yeah. That's how I can sell it to you.
You will never have to bend over.
You'll never have to bend to the knee.
Amazing dude. And that was like my gift to my parents that I went to Japan.
Cause I was, I couldn't bring it with me. So I was like, parents,
you can have my price per se.
Here's the vacuum. I'm like, I'm like bending.
You're over like giving them like the sort of Camelot, like, here you go.
Take it. Take my Dyson. V12. Max suck edition
should be fair. But she.
Well, it was all nonsense, but she tried it. She was like, all right, corner.
This is a pretty good kid. [inaudible].